hey guys david then back it resent
kitchen table and you pretty much know
more about movies than anyone that i
know is that what does that say about
people either we know hundreds of people
who know more about movies than I be but
you're paid to know about movie I got it
but some people know yeah yeah regular
people aguilar p alright well i have to
look up a lot I thought that Ben knows a
lot about movie though still pretty I
know a lot about you know I'm Emily so
one thing that was really interesting is
there's been a lot written last week or
so about how 2014 was the worst year in
the box office since 1995 mmm uh and you
know this probably good Julian reasons
for this I read a lot of theories you
know TV is back everyone saying it's the
Golden Age of TV again uh in the
internet apparently people are watching
things on the internet right um but I
think there's probably more to it so I
wanted to get your your take on what do
you think's going on with the movies I
don't think there is more than that I'll
be out doing that's it people just are
not leaving home yeah and I think
there's you know statistical noise it's
not it wasn't such a dramatic drop you
know i mean i think it was five little
over five percent down from from 2013 uh
that can happen in any given year
because you might not you know depending
on what kinds of movies come out next
year with so many highly anticipated
sequels to to uh properties that
audiences cherish yeah i suspect the
numbers will go back up yeah but what
we're gonna do another video on that
necessities next year's gonna be it's
gonna be bananas yeah but i think that
in general if you know it i don't think
this was a great year for movies i think
this was a really good year for the kind
of movies that people don't see ya and
not a great year for the movies that are
either a oscar contenders or many of the
big sequels they were you know it was ok
there was ordinary was nothing
incredibly exciting and I think that's
reflected to the numbers you'd have to
see a another five percent drop in 2015
a five percent drop in 2016 before you
could say that this is a trend right so
how much of it though is you think the
movies themselves were like right now
when I see like there's certain things
that I want to see in the theater like
interstellar I was like all right that I
ought be
we have to go see in the theater I saw
it at the Chinese Theater here and it
was absolutely amazing versus a lot of
the other things it's like a CL the ti
no it's not that poor ground in here he
lost what is what cities that they don't
care about it anymore um these but they
don't mazing thing to that theater miss
beautiful yeah really restorative um so
there's certain things that you want to
go to the movie theater for right and
then there's others were I'm just like
aah you know it's just some little indie
whatever like why bother why would have
to leave home pay 15 bucks per ticket
blah blah blah when I can get it on
appletv a month later for a dollar night
so I I think that's more of it than just
that the I think that's some of it I
think that obviously if you make it
comfortable for people to see stuff at
home some people will see stuff at home
yeah I I think we look too hard for
trends yeah people been going to movies
uh since you know the teens you know and
and there's a collective environment
they're people like to go out yeah also
there and if people start staying in all
the time to see movies in a few years
they'll be like a you know what's great
going out to all that ready just as
easily say why would I be 49i when I
could sit at home and they'll go you
know I was gonna sit at home again on
Friday night when I could go out I could
have a meal I could go out with my
husband or wife a boyfriend or
girlfriend your buddies and have a great
time at the movie so I think what is
clearly incumbent upon theaters to do
and we've seen more this in Los Angeles
than a lot of other places is enhance
the theater experience you know theaters
sighs when I visit a friend even when I
visit a buddy in Las Vegas and I go to a
movie in Vegas talked you know I mean
the theater right sky it you can't see
the dirt but it feels dirty either too
cold or too hot Vicky from the popcorns
dear hope it's the pop and that depends
we got a theater but exactly yet yeah uh
and and and and you know and the sight
lines aren't great but the stadium
seating in LA where you can buy your
seat ahead of time and could pick where
you want I said oh can't believe that by
the way cuz I'm only two years into la
that I can actually buy my seat and show
up one minute before and I can will be
waiting a totally and I I do that
you know cuz I don't like when I go to I
see a lot of movies you know in the
critic screens but when I do a movie
like it's great i like to see trail I
like previews yeah I don't want to know
anything about what's coming uh so I
like to get their movie starts at twelve
fit as a 1205 show I like to get their
1220 right you know right right before
the feature starts and do that here so I
think it's incumbent on theaters to
enhance that experience bring the food
up make it more of an event rather than
just piling people into a theater that
was built in the to House people in 1977
yes oh speaking of the event thing I
think actually for me the the biggest
movie event for me this year was I saw a
bird man at arclight which is a big
famous theater here in la at the dome
which is there it's a really sad old oh
yeah it's really cool um but what I
thought was really cool about it was I
saw like the first we came out and it
was so out you know the whole movies
about la in showbiz and blah blah blah
and that all the people in the audience
clearly were in showbiz and all that and
I noticed that even the laughter
reminded me of a comedy club when you
there's a certain type of laughter that
you hear live versus a typo laughter
that you hear on television um so
they're saying so nice about that that
experience so there is something that
you you lose if you don't see something
with some other humans right yeah I mean
it you know I don't you know and by the
way no question the one thing you
mentioned old age television the shows
are incredible yeah that's writing right
now is happening on television not in
movies and nobody really cares about how
these some of the superhero movies are
written in the sequel they movie to me
they feel very similar yeah I'm not a
fanboy and I don't begrudge the fanboys
but those movies feel really repetitive
to me really repetitive and I think
there may be some we got it he was bit
by a radioactive spider I mean right
there's some sort of a collective
fatigue yeah we may have fell to that
but there's some about going to an event
a shared experience it matters like I
don't want these goalies wonderful shows
like when you know Downton Abbey just
started this week and then you know I
mean and my wife was working on her
computer I was like come on come on I
don't know what you working on your
computer let's watch yes I wanna you
know I want to laugh at people with her
yeah you know now so you did watch
Dancing I watched out have here I will
admit right now this
pretty pathetic I watched the premiere
of The Apprentice instead of Downton
Abbey I have it waiting for me I can't
believe I can't believe I just publicly
I don't know why it's the only reality
show i watch I don't know why the rating
piece of [ __ ] Donald Trump and freaking
Geraldo like these retreads getting on
television and working with NBC gosh
pathetic but then it goes wrong with you
man what is wrong with you it's a good
question what's wrong with me let me
know in the comments right down below